- one hello Mike hey Joe hello pant pant
telus pant you call me pant pant pant
Ellis pant Ellis one one word yeah one
more like Roseanne more like Godzilla
okay cool alright dude well nice to meet
you guys
well nice met you yeah but nice to meet
you for people who don't know let's just
give them right off the bat your story
what happened to you how you got in
trouble in Canada for a joke yeah real
trouble yeah real talk I got fined
$42,000 of Canadian American Canadian
which was like now close to 40 mm yeah
yeah it was yeah let's say like
thirty-eight thousand American and
there's a thing in Canada called the
Human Rights Commission that every
province has one of those I had a joke
about um a little boy that was famous he
was a singer he was a disabled boy and
the the joke it wasn't even that mean it
was just this little kid that was
disabled and he was uh m'as kind of like
a make-a-wish Foundation type kid right
and he was famous in Canada he was
famous in French Canada he had sang for
the Pope and the the joke was but like I
was super happy for him at first this
little deaf boy he's dying he his dream
was to sing for the Pope and then he
became like like front-page news on you
know everywhere in Montreal and then he
got a record deal then he sang for the
Canadians then he came out with a book
and then at the end I was like why isn't
he dead yet like wasn't he supposed to
die that's just the right the base
system like he's a little dark joke yeah
yeah like it's what I do is dark humor
like I'm not I'm not
Ray Romano right so I did that joke and
in never did that joke on TV did that
joke in a special that it didn't air on
TV I cut a couple of things out for TV
but I get a letter from the human rights
people saying you owe 80 at first it was
they wanted eighty two thousand for the
joke they were like we listened to the
joke we think that this boy's family
deserves eighty two thousand because of
this joke what a weird number yeah and I
thought I thought they were like it is
how [ __ ] stupid I am when I got the
letter
I saw Human Rights Commission I thought
I was getting an award or a prize or
something because I I do I do a lot of
benefits and suffered for I raise money
for disabled people so I was like [ __ ]
it's a bad time they recognize me as a
good dude so I read this and then I
called my manager and I'm like [ __ ] they
want 80,000 and we were like okay let's
just get the best lawyer we can so I
found the best lawyer in Canada that
does a free speech stuff met him and he
told me the reason why it was 80,000
80,000 is a weird number like if they
ask two million you're gonna fight it
but 80,000 is big enough to kind of
scare you but not enough to really scare
you so you'll go like look okay can I
give you 40 and then they'll go okay you
can ask your question so this bit you
said you cut it from the special right
so how did they know about it it was uh
I did this interview on TV and the the
reporter talked about the bit he had
never seen the bit also how did he know
about the bed ah someone told him about
the bit but the bit was in the special
in the special so it was on the Internet
also you could watch it yeah you could
watch it on the Internet and this
special had been in movie theatres in
Canada it's just when we sold it on TV
right is this in French or anything it
was in French that's always weird
whenever people were talking about the
bit they were like it was especially in
Canada and in England where it's very
left-leaning people were were talking
[ __ ] about the bit and I was like you
you can't even understand that joke
that's in a language you don't speak
about a person you don't know so they
people almost made it look like I just
picked this random disabled boy and I
was making fun of his disability but I
was making fun of the fact that he had
become famous because everyone thought
he was dying and then he didn't die
which is a you know it's a dark joke so
it is yes not even that particularly
mean no it's a question really you're
not saying hey why don't you die I spent
money you little [ __ ] you can say that
no you said how come he's alive yeah
exactly yeah and when I did the the
thing for TV I cut a couple things out
that I thought could get me in trouble
because
I figured you know when you put out a
special and people pay for the special
you should be allowed and I still think
this and you know this I think everyone
should think this way if like if you put
out a special you should be allowed to
say whatever the [ __ ] you want to say
but if you sell your special to like CBS
or ABC then of course they're gonna cut
[ __ ] out of course but like your last
special on Netflix it would be crazy if
Netflix said look Joe we [ __ ] loved
your special but this you got to cut
this out you got to cut welcome to
Netflix credit that's one of the reasons
why they're so amazing they don't give
you hardly any input at all there's to
go hey we really liked it
it's like they don't do anything yeah
they you know I had some controversial
[ __ ] in this one in my last one they
just let it go that's much appreciated
yeah